moi je crois pas que dans toute ma vie
je n'ai eu envie de faire qu'une seule
chose j'étais gourmands des activités
que je savais faire et je voulais les
embrasser tout à tort j'aurais dû être
moins ambitieux
[Musique]
je ne crois plus les filles
avec leurs soucis
d'abord tapé nom bien célèbre un homme
d'affaires connu par monts et par vaux
qui dirige d'état d'état d'état d'état
société
[Musique]
moi je marche à l'envers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne suis pas socialiste puisque je
suis pas inscrit au parti socialiste
et il est difficile de dire je suis de
gauche parce qu'on sait plus très bien
où se trouve la frontière et qu'est-ce
qui délimite la droite de la gauche
lausanne notamment vous êtes un tartarin
un bluffeur c'est pas parce que vous
avez une grande gueule et vous crier
fort que vous arrivez
le
différend la seule différence c'est que
c'est pas parce que vous affirmez fort
quelque chose que ce que vous dites est
vrai parce que vous dites n'importe quoi
messieurs le pitre monsieur vous à venir
étaler attention vous
savez je me passe mad énormités comme ça
c'est pas possible
monsieur station mal et vous en cuir est
parce que vous avez vos gardes du corps
n'ont pas moi
enfin regardez c'est parce qu'on
déculpabilise ceux qui se trouvent une
bonne raison qu'on a un front national
si fort car si le pm est un salon ceux
qui votent pour eux sont des il
ya toute une seule couleur c'est leur
engagement oui on ne garde pas non non
non les rendements est ce que vous allez
d utiliser votre avis ou pas sérieux la
politique
vous l'avez encensée et vous avez dit
que c'était un homme formidable
ces 10 était un bon ministre et il me
semble je ne suis pas très compétent que
c'était un bon patron de l'olympique de
marseille
et savez vous paraît inexactes non ça me
parait large et des rites olympique de
marseille est un grand club pour le
reste
les affaires judiciaires je n'y connais
rien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi avez vous le sentiment à ce
point d'être persécutés comme s'il y
avait un faux médias les juges des
politiques est ce que vous imaginez un
seul instant que le lendemain chez moi
alors la nuit non mais attendez
on dit ici qui à défaut chez vous non
non non le fait qu'ils roditis il ya des
faux chéri je redis que je ne me menace
est pas allé non merci beaucoup à tous
non non non non
ben voilà bah vous répondrai pas aux
questions merci en tout cas d'être venu
c'est ça vous dérange pas la justice
faire son boulet absolument et mais il
est pas quel sort il n'est pas question
d'intérêt arrêté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
y'a pas un euros exigible de créances
c'est du spectacle
ça fait partie du parcours improbable
quand on a 70 ans et plus faut accepter
qu'à un moment donné on va aller vers
l'épreuve ultime qui étaient là qu'est
la mort et pour moi c'est pas c'est pas
de catastrophe j'ai vécu d'une manière
incroyable formidable chanceux